all right yes so it's great to be here
this conference and let's dive in so I
think I'm gonna have some some things to
say that will potentially mesh or a jar
with previous ideas that we've heard so
far and possibly ideas that will heal
afterwards so that's great it's exactly
why we're here let me provide a sort of
five minute or less kind of intuition to
how I'm thinking about what replay
sequences are about so I'm going to tell
you about this phenomenon replay quick
show of hands who's heard of replaying
knows a little bit about what it is
that's most people so I think it's okay
to do it this way around but we'll of
course explain what it is later so
imagine your wrap exploring a maze and
you're at Alamein Ian's rep so Edward
Talman who in the thirties and forties
were at Berkeley
actually all the way through to the 60s
and he famously hypothesized that the
rat bills are come to map of the
environment and this was a we actually
gets the very simple stimulus response
models that were current at the time so
our rat is slowly building up this map
as he explores this environment right
and the point here is that you can do
this very quickly meaning he only has to
experience a transition here a movement
once to be able to know that that's a
possible place he can go so we sort of
think of this model learning as fast to
learn I've in that sense now eventually
built up the whole model and now he's in
the maze and the question is what does
he do
where does he go which way should he go
to get out
okay now latency was about three seconds
it's a little complicated because you've
got to read the map and what your eyes
do is they scan ahead and try to figure
out and there are more efficient
algorithms but whichever way you do it
there's still a problem to be solved
even if you have a map so in that sense
models can be slow to use and this was
the famous criticism that Talman was
subjected to
although albeit before any kind of
mathematical formalism which was that he
his map left his rats buried in thought
that's a bad thing if you're running
away from a predator the other
alternative that classically distinguish
the alternative approach is what's
called muddle free here the idea is that
you make multiple samples of actual
behaviors and you can slowly build up
some notion of how valuable all of the
places in this environment is one sort
of one trial at the time so you find
some food and then you know that this
all right don't worry too much about the
specific representation there's
different ways in which it can be
equivalent but you find that this
location is important because it was
followed by food it's one step away from
the food and then another trial you come
in and you realize that this location is
close to this location so you can move
the reward information back a little bit
and so on and so on and eventually you
can end up with a representation that
has some expectation of how far far away
you are from the goal but it takes many
many many trials I mean to converge
right so it's slow to learn but it's
fast to use because it gives you exactly
the local information that you want so
when you're in a particular position you
know in locally which is the step that
is takes you one step close to the goal
this idea has been captured as a
trade-off that animals may want to trade
off these two kinds of learning model
based and model free for example in the
Nathaniel Door has talked about this it
would be a very impoverished model where
you basically just know you don't even
have a sequence you have a
representation of each location and with
that representation you can associate
something such as a expectation and a
scalar quantity like value so actually
this model free doesn't know anything
about the shape of this it just learns
through trial and error and builds up
this value function you have the sheep
so it's usually thought of as a
trade-off but in fact what you'd really
like to do is encode your experiences
with the model and make your decisions
with model with a model free system
because what exploration is expensive
right and indecision is expensive so the
question is can you do this and it's
almost a corollary of the fact that
exploration is expensive and the
decision is expensive therefore animals
don't spend a lot of time doing those
activities in which case they must have
a lot of time doing needs we think of
these as offline states red states where
the animals are basically not subjecting
themselves to the danger being eaten and
there's so much time that maybe there's
some process you can use where you can
your model can teach your model free
system and you'll know what to do and
that is essentially the way I'm thinking
about replay value function easier when
you have the model of thing what I meant
I thought it was easier
when you have a mile in the environment
but you start to learning stuff to
derive the transition function and and
the way to think about this is that this
is actually a very small impoverished
transition function for the actual
decision space states based in animal
faces in its in its environment
so the actual real world goals of an
animal and if these are not just
locations but other states that the
animal has to make decisions in that's a
very very large state space has to be
searched through and even if you use
efficient algorithms like value
iteration it's still going to take some
time what you'd like to have is the
values right there locally and the
actions ready to go so this is how I'm
thinking about it let's talk about the
data you've already heard about these
cells ca1 pyramidal cells in the
hippocampus and I can introduce this but
we were recording in freely moving
animals and with isolating
extracellularly action potentials from
large numbers of cells simultaneously
and I probably don't introduce this but
this is a typical hippocampal place cell
so what you're looking at is an animal
running up and down a track that's about
two meters long sweeping back and forth
this is about 20 minutes of time this is
his position the gray is the location he
sweeps and then stops and sweeps and
stops he's actually eating something at
either end and on top you see this
hippocampal place cell fires in one
location okay so that's the you can
capture that as a one-dimensional place
field across a number of these cells
recorded simultaneously you typically
find that different cells do the same
thing but in different locations so
that's in that sense that we have a map
of the environment yeah so on the on the
on the on oh yeah on the linear track
many of these will be directions
selective and each cell to a different
degree but when we do population
decoding we can
clearly pick out the difference between
one direction and another as well as the
position so a few things about play
sales just do it consciously and
although that's not necessarily the
focus of this session but competitive to
something like grid cells they're
spatially stable right they do the same
thing every time in the same place and
they cover the intervening space so this
is like a hierarchy in my mind of
spatial patristic spatially stable would
also be true for any recommendations
that are anchored to a movie you know if
you if the animal touches something in
the environment that's fairly fixed as a
spatially stable allocentric signal but
but this way he has them everywhere and
so that's sort of why this is so useful
including places where there wouldn't be
any local cues to define those locations
they're not particularly geometric this
has sort of been a long-standing theme
and you know in asking how spatial these
cells are now with grid cells we have
these very compelling sort of
geometrical representations but these
come in all sorts of different shapes
and sizes so quickly getting to don't
have a particular shape you have a
particular shape and it's not obvious
how you would derive quantities like
metric quantities like distance from
them any model-based approach that you
can just build build something model to
be out of it so you can just do the
learning once and then that's it
do the learning winter sir yes that's
what I'm gonna do
let me show let me show you how that
works so here's the animal running from
one end of the track to the other okay
and then being stationary this is a
minute now okay so this is like a few
seconds and then he's stationary at one
position and these are the 19 cells
firing in their classical place feels
alright but what you can see here is
while the animal stationary there's all
this other activity going on and you
know just to jump to the punchline here
this activity if we just zoom in the
x-axis its activity is is structured in
this case it's what we call a reverse
replay because the cells that fire in
the current location fire first but then
all the way all the other cells all the
way back to the beginning of the track
and this is a couple hundred
milliseconds condensing this two or
three second experience but the thing is
this is happening many many many times
and let me just the 12 strongest events
here are these okay so you can see
there's very actually that's 14 okay
there's very distinct and repeatable
patterns so if we go back I just want to
make a few points about this this
activity is actually also structured
because it's happening during a theta
rhythm
so each theta cycle you just get a few
spikes from each cells each cell so that
the sort of local environment for these
cells in terms of spiking looks very
similar here to here here the cells of
the firing in little bursts of one two
or three spikes and you know within tens
of milliseconds to other cells they're
represented in a adjacent positions and
the same thing is true over here so the
you know but there's a lot more of these
right so there might be five or six and
theta cycles here but this depends on
how long the animal stays here and in
this particular task is staying here for
a minute and then he's turning around
I was evolution but in general and if
I'm right about just my hunch about
exploration being expensive
in general rats would have very long
periods of time whether we're just
sitting around not engaging activity and
they have all this time to do processing
and the point here I want to make is
that this processing is happening and
and and these highly structured offline
runs through of trajectories are
happening yeah and so I didn't met you
because I'm not gonna say much in this
talk but this is their local EEG which
is also being recorded in phases one of
these channels just filtered differently
to pick up rhythms and the local food
potential right so this is filtered for
the ripple frequency of 100 to 200 these
these events happen during these
so-called shockwave replicas so reverse
replay
you know we perhaps a bit
counterintuitive but we we had come up
with this model just to make sense of it
which is that you can actually use this
to learn some kind of value function so
don't take the this part too seriously
because this could be many different
circuits that do it but the key point is
if you have some kind of faster onset
slowly decaying reward signal then if
it's happening at the same time as a
reverse replay then you're pairing
meaning co-occurring you're pairing
these cells that fire close to the world
with very high levels of this signal and
less and less and less as you go back to
the beginning of the track and these
pulses of dopamine seem to have actually
have the the right time scale for this
so the consequence of this would be that
cells place else would then acquire this
kind of grading Association and we in
very indirectly found some evidence to
support that so let me explain this is a
busy slide so I'm not going to talk
about at all
this is the slide I used to say that
this kind of funny reverse replay was
replicated by other people
but I'm going to focus on this this is
deeper in berserk II who showed that in
fact and this is the other way round
from the way I showed it sorry but here
you have the classic place filled
activity of a bunch of cells as the
animal traverses a track but just
afterwards you get the reverse replay
and just before the animal sets off you
get a forwards reach so I want to
explain to you here is that because of
the directionality of cells that was
mentioned before different cells are
firing in each direction of the track
this period during which you get forward
to replay of this direction you're
always you're also going to get reverse
replay of the other direction right
that's the flip side of this you know if
we were imagine this same figure for the
animal moving the other direction you'd
have both of these so that's the idea
actually and we verified that so during
stopping periods you actually have
forward and reverse replays intermingled
yes yes indeed bouzouki so yes okay so
so we didn't explain recently where we
had three epochs of running on a track
and we either increased the reward at
one end during the middle I poked or we
actually get rid of it I talked about
this it's actually a bit more
complicated because of behavior but here
it's very simple the animal runs up and
down continues to run but down but a one
end in the middle I poke the each epoch
is something like fifteen running laps
and then there's a break and then 15
running laps and then there's a break in
there in the middle he's getting four
times the amount of liquid chocolate and
just to get to the punchline here that
has an effect on shock waves ripple rate
which was actually shown by Lorenz
Lauren Frank a few years ago it turns
out when you look at replay that effect
is also there but it's only really
affecting the reverse replays
so these reverse and forwards are all
intermingled but only the reverse
replays are showing an increase in
replay rate and in fact we found the
same thing when we decrease the amount
of reward get rid of the words only the
reverse showed a statistically
significant effect it's complicated by
the fact that the behavior of the animal
completely changes in this case because
he doesn't go to food he doesn't wait
around so he moves but we actually found
interesting effects at the you know at
the other end now becomes sort of more
valuable but in the interest of time I
won't talk about that just focus on this
but it's showing that reverse replay
seems to have a relationship to reward
which is in line with what we predicted
the function of reverse replay would be
that it's trying to encode something
about the rewards and send that
information back along the incoming
trajectory forwards replay then has some
other role to be so it would so there
are changes that occur here for example
the now the relative amount relative
value might think of this reward which
is unchanged as increased and you
actually get an increase of reverse
replays but not forwards replays here
and when you bring back your reinstate
the reward you now these two rewards are
the same but you get a relative increase
now this is actually as an increased
rate over this so that we interpreted
that as in line with again for
experimental reasons perhaps we're
finding increases easier to detect the
decreases but the increases follow some
of the properties of the dopamine signal
at Wiktionary signal and that there's a
menu effect here and a kind of
prediction error and affect history
effect here
ever test whether the decrease or
increase of these rates is there
anything about its patterns sharp ways
that changes also or do those you know
all of these events look the same it's
just fewer versus more we we only looked
at it in terms of few of us as more and
maybe we can and nothing struck me over
so you can see the events and nothing
struck as is different what do you have
in mind there are differences that occur
in replays which forgetting body we
didn't see that as a punch of reward but
you know it's the kind of thing that you
know always collecting data on it so it
might be there now quickly because a
previous mention I should mention that
we've been very interested in the idea
of learning so I the sequence is learned
and so I'm gonna go over this very
quickly but you know we found no
evidence for pre play and that's
something that we had were very
interested in one of and so I'm not
actually going to talk about the way we
addressed pre play we we actually
replicated the methods of the pre play
papers and found statistical errors in
those methods that I can talk about if
somebody wants to know about it I will
just show this data though which is you
know the best sequences we can find in
one session on the track and the best
sequences that you can see you know
during an hour of sleep beforehand and
now we're using this position estimation
decoding technique to sort of see the
sequence is very clearly across
something like 80 play cells recorded
simultaneously but you can see it's very
easy to detect sequences as soon as the
animal starts running but you don't see
anything
beforehand I'll skip that so this is
particularly interesting because we
think we've established that there's no
prior sequences but earlier our early
results had shown that you can see
sequences even after the first lap on a
novel track so for right about this
these sequences are forming very rapidly
now that's exactly what I'd said the
model should do I should be able to
encode your experience very quickly and
then start using that to train other
systems to make use of it how do you
look at these population events when you
put me out on the track but before it
runs that first class you're looking at
the sleep before that right yeah yeah so
in this paper we did actually use that
and there was because it's 30 because
there's a novel track the animal will
sit there for like up to 5 minutes as he
sort of decides what he really wants to
play along or not and yeah there was no
no sequences at all during those periods
so that was actually in the original
paper I will mention this one other
study which gets the question that I was
asking Lawrence would be so this is a
paper my students shouting whoo did
early on in our lab and we caught it on
his teammates so the task is normally in
alternation although the animals not
that familiar with it it's come the
state it comes from very early in the
training process but the animals
exploring both sides of is exploring all
possible trajectories basically on this
track but we find plentiful replays at
each of the stopping points and we
considered that there might be two ways
in which these replays are generated
right there may be different pieces
corresponding to the different possible
entire trajectories as if you have
pre-existing sequences and your map
something to them or the neurons
representing different positions might
literally in some sense become stitched
together in some
Oh plastic process that comes to
resemble it's a neural level that the
track itself and so we found that you
know there were cells that fired their
cells in general fired in when they
fired during the replays they took part
in both of these kinds of replays and
despite the fact that this is just
showing the firing rate of 80 something
cells during replays replace the start
here and end here or start here and end
here there's a blue line in a red line
you probably can't see it very well
because they're on top of each other so
the individual cells have very different
firing rates you know themselves are
firing a lot some of the little but they
show no difference between whether
they're firing as part of a replay that
goods appear or replay goes up here and
that was generally true and we could
shuffle the identity and show there's no
difference in the firing rates so
essentially the cells are acting and in
the same way in both of the in both of
these kinds of sequences so we think
this model is the correct one to see
what you know vanilla seeing one dorsal
expect some difference because of the
this is just from this is the C part of
the sequence okay yeah
so I know I'm running out of time I just
want you one more thing which is so a
more recent work we we looked at the
classic linear track again but with much
larger numbers of place cells recorded
than had been used before and I think
something like 200 cells and what you're
looking at is a replay event that's
being depicted in two dimensions
position using this position decoding
but collapsed in time so you're not
seeing time here you can imagine that at
successive frames of time we would have
had different parts of this replay event
showing up and we've just summed it all
together
so the remarkable thing is these gaps
right so we now have better coverage
across this then in fact than we've ever
had before and yet there are gaps in the
representation and when you and I didn't
make a movie here but what you find is
the replay will hovers and then jumps
hovers jumps hovers jumps has that
dynamics and it's nice because the again
Lorenz lab had shown that spiking during
these shock wave ripples can be
modulated by the what's called slow
gamma 25 to 50 Hertz
rhythm associated with C 3 here we
showed so that that is true but also
this hovering and jumping the
information content is also similarly
modulated so it really is the case that
within a roughly 30 millisecond period
you've got it hover in a jump so what do
we what do we make of this so this now
maybe we should take with a grain of
salt
but it was an old idea that if you want
to study
Etra specifically a bunch of items in a
hot film then this will break down by
itself I mean I think the idea here is
you have a well store
sequence view but if you have to store
fresh and just learn online patterns
then generally speaking it's not a very
stable pattern retrieval mechanism
hopeful actually no that isn't no need
to 1982 paper what you get the
guarantees for with hop caneta sort
association they will relax to the
attractor state so it's an old idea and
I think the last time I talked about
this actually a few years ago and race
Hertz had something to say but this
that's what you say so he wants me to
atone it but the idea was that that what
you wanted to do was have fast synapses
to era-correct individual items and
slower synapses to move and then what I
think is correct about that is you can
store sequence is very reliable using
that mechanism that doesn't mean there
couldn't be other mechanisms and then
the lake john lisman had proposed this
as a model by which c3 caused or
sequences during theta so that's our
basic conception that this dynamics now
which is only available to us because of
the number of neurons we recorded at the
same time millisecond I've got to make
this plug for electro physiologically
it's very it's just the case that if we
with calcium imaging right now all of
this is what I love calcium imaging all
of this is not available to us because
you know it isn't the entire replay
sequence is happening within 100 or 200
milliseconds but now this dynamics is
happening on the order of tens of
milliseconds right and we think that
within each you know we predict that
within each slow down a cycle you're
actually going to have a strengthening
of the representation that during this
hover so this information in there which
is going to be hard to get for any other
means and the idea was maybe this
reflects the circuitry so may at ca3
well I won't belabor that point because
that's interesting so
one of the most robust effects in my lab
across everybody's dataset is the
progressive change and replay that
happens with experience doing during a
session I you often see replays they
start off fast and they get slower he's
a little counterintuitive you might
think that if you're increasing the
synaptic drive or increasing you know
something's being learned that this
should get these sequences should get
faster they should recruit more spikes
and so on but they should get faster but
it gets slower this actually makes
perfect sense from the point of view of
the value learning that I was talking
about right at the beginning because
often in these RL models you want you
have different needs at the beginning of
training at at the end of training at
the beginning of training you want to
you don't know anything anyway and you
need to get that information out into
the environment meaning your
representations of other places need to
learn something fast and so replay
sequence that within a let's say fixed
synaptic window for downstream systems
you need to get that information from
one part of the environment to the other
quickly later on you now need to smooth
out the inconsistencies and reduce their
you care less about bias and more about
variants they want a smaller synaptic
window so I can see
two things one is that we we think that
this process of elongated the replays
actually corresponds to the
strengthening of these attractors and
then I will entirely skip and give you
my in three seconds my three minutes
what's the biggest question right
because that's somebody wondering the
most pressing question we play has been
reported in other parts of the brain yes
but it's still that sort of 1990s
hippocampal replay where you know
there's a bit of a correlation or maybe
some hint of a sequence and now we're
seeing in the hippocampus that there's
this highly structured activity it's it
suggests all sorts of complexity and
structure that could have all sorts of
functions but the hippocampus is by
itself a technical accident the only
place I would say that replay has really
been looked for at that kind of
resolution it's the only place where
people have routinely recorded from
hundreds of cells at a millisecond
resolution and if you don't do that you
don't see any of this stuff so the
question for me is if the hippocampus a
special thing is replay a special
hippocampus thing that has something to
do with memory consolidation or value
learning or is replay ubiquitous and
every area of the brain that has
recurrent circuitry every part of cortex
and many other parts too has this kind
of rich dynamics in which case we would
have to quite seriously revise many of
the ways that we think about information
processing in the brain and
I think well they throw thing there I
didn't get it are you saying it's
related to the previous discussion that
we had are you saying provided evidence
for or against that these sequences are
sort of pre-programmed random sequences
that that then attach to the external
sequences in the world or they are being
trained representations of the actual
trajectories of the analysts which one
was your cousin I'm sorry yeah so the
the finding is reported of pre-play is
that there are sequences of neurons
firing that come to be mapped on to
places subsequently experienced so that
so that if you form your template out of
the experiences you can go and look
previously in time and find those replay
like sequences before the experience was
ever took place and we find no evidence
for that and we found we think errors in
the original analyses suggesting that
that has not been demonstrated doesn't
necessarily mean I mean maybe the
ratchet doesn't when it's not moving it
just isn't pre-planned
but but that doesn't seem to rule out
the hypothesis that the sequences then
once the animal starts moving are being
generated we're kind of these random
hash codes well you could generate
random hash code on the fly right but
you're suggesting that the the power of
this is that they're already you know
imprinted into the system so that this
and right which is fascinating but I
would say there's I mean my most extreme
statement about that is that don't
believe there's any evidence that stands
up that's been shown that that is occurs
so we're sort of back at 2010 and it
might but it's logically inconsistent
with several of the findings that we
have that sequences come to quickly
represent complicated you know
t-junctions and other structures in
spatial structures in such a way that
after just a few trials they can be
sequences can be generated from them so
that's my so I'm wondering about the
discrete chunks if you observe anything
from what I think we know about play
says there's no evidence the states and
the InFocus are discrete and we also
know that it's possible to construct the
tractor models that have this property
that have a continuum so you imagine the
discrete states reflect sweetness and
extract estates available you see three
four that they reflect some choice in
the wiring up you're asking if they're
functional in the third experience like
this you can have a different replays
can use different different sets of
let's just call them hovering points so
they can vary although there's you know
I mean actually the full study of this
is yet to be done where we cluster them
and show that you know there's actually
an interesting you know probably just a
small number of possible sets of public
lines but it's it's not the case that
you're stuck with the animals completely
stuck with dead zones where you can't
replay and retrieve any information so
it doesn't happen there's also it's very
surprising I just expected that as we
added more more cells we'd see more more
smoothness and that I would say we have
strong evidence that that's not the case
so I don't know what to make it
so anyhow conceptualization of events
based learning but what is the actual
experiment that shows that really you
know planning and value based learning
are based on these sequences right I
mean it is the case that you know some
learning like Lauryn Ward is going
Johnny yeah
well I think the yeah I guess we've
several it was me chasing this but it's
bit elusive but that's to see the value
function itself well you might know
Lawrence agree with you but might be
thinking I was going somewhere else with
it but one thing is seeing the value
function itself right we there's bits
and pieces suggesting that cells in the
nucleus accumbens for example might ramp
up their activity on the approach to a
goal but that you know what I'm talking
about see what I think we're talking
about is quite a quite sophisticated
value functions right because any given
task is going to be quite a bit more
complex than just a single approach to a
goal and so you know you could say well
it's very unlikely to have a value
function is so contorted and and complex
but the replays are there and they're
pretty contorted and complex so but
we've been recording in nucleus
accumbens it's difficult in the
responses don't they don't fit that
model yet so we're interested I think
they should be of some kind of value
function or pieces of a value function
we should have some notion of how this
contributes eventually to decision
making but that's really not just
following up I totally agree with
everything you said and I just you know
I mean my sense is this is a hypothesis
that's all it is right now right it's a
guide for us to plan our experiments the
thing I was gonna ask about was certain
related to an implicit in illis question
this is slightly selfish given what I'll
be talking about later do you mind doing
it 10 or 15 second or 30-second summary
of the stuff you skipped on future stuff
well I won't say anything this is a
video
real-time and shortwave time stuff
happening so you can watch that and I'll
answer jury yeah is there an easy way to
relate this to the two dimensional maps
and the simulation story and all that
what happens in two dimensions so
actually with this kind of stuff happens
in two dimensions so you get replay
sequences that are focused in one
location so they don't fan out that's
kind of interesting and they often
predict or seem to predict what the
animal is going to do next so there's
this part of the story that we haven't
fully got to grips with is the idea that
sometimes this these events may actually
relate more to planning immediately
behavior and that's what I said reverse
replay sequences were for failure and
they make sense these forward sequences
may also have a different they have a
different role but you know the jury is
not out on this and there is interesting
modeling work coming out of Nataniel
doors lab right now suggesting that
there may be an integrated perspective
where everything is value learning even
the forward sequences so I'm sorry I
didn't really talk about that in more
detail but there's a very rich and
interesting set of they have activity
patterns that you get in two dimensions
that looks like the animals thinking
about what he's doing okay
okay next the last question
it's really playing
again I have only hypothesis but the we
have been thinking about it recently is
that you know the latest results in from
the spike time dependent plasticity
people say that under various new multi
legged neuromodulatory conditions you
can have perfectly symmetric plasticity
so there's there's modelling work by I
mean it comes out of sample in skis were
basically showing that you you can do
symmetry but if you've got symmetry
connections you you have some method of
you have a book on a hill you can squash
the bump and make it move and you can
you can have you need some kind of
momentum to keep that replay moving
there's ways to make that happen but
basically you can have symmetric
connections forwards in Reverse
generated during behavior and you can
have a reverse and forwards replace come
out of that one day rich in Lawrence's
framework
how can you play yeah I'm doing a bad
job but so you do this right these are
the these are the places right what I'm
suggesting is in plasticity terms you do
this
and then you might think that if you're
sitting here you don't go anywhere but
there are ways to squash that bump and
make it move so there are ways to do
this models that work is fundamentally
liking to generate ABCDE
it probably doesn't like to generate the
opposite I mean that's just okay
evaluation you're saying that you're
using what you learned in the context of
rewards to do what the replays do the
value functions over your map and then
use that related navigation under
positions where you weren't being
awarded say because you're satiated
right you shouldn't be able to use that
map decisions like that I wouldn't make
that prediction because the
the model said there's two things like
this model learning and that is
integrating the reward and you know I'm
the director to make it up that I can
say model learning can proceed you know
in the absence in latent learning style
yams just sampling transitions and
and do we know this I'm not sure if we
know this though because I don't really
believe mass replay yet and already
reflex payments have some kind of reward
in them but if you can sample the reward
the environment without a new reward I
would have no problem believe me you can
replay it and then the integration with
reward to generate value function is a
survey okay
[Applause]